I want you to imagine waking up and all
the clocks in your house have stopped
maybe there's a blackout something like
that for reasons that you don't know
your phone is dead maybe because of the
blackout you put into charge overnight
and it didn't charge so it's you have no
sense of what the current time is and
you know you could you know probably go
outside and ask someone but you have
this question in your mind for how to
accurately reset your clock now how
would you work out without any kind of
technology or any other person be able
to help you how would you be able to
work out for example what time mid day
should be how would you set that what
knowledge or observation would you make
anyway what do you think yeah fantastic
the sun's position is usually how we
describe midday right midday the middle
of the day 12:00 p.m.
I guess who had roughly expected to be
halfway between sunset
sorry sunrise and sunset would you agree
that's kind of what you would expect on
any given day no matter what time in the
year okay now the problem with this is
that this is a trickier question to
answer than is first apparent and the
reason why is because we live on one of
these now the earth being round causes
huge problems for time for starters if
you think about where we're sort of in
spring right now so it's kind of like a
normal part of you but you guys know in
winter and summer time works a little
bit differently when you think about the
Sun coming up and setting as well for
example sorry I'm just going to switch
over to something for example if you go
to a spot like the Antarctic if it's
summer in the Antarctic the the Sun
never sets this is a time-lapse
following the path of the Sun over a
24-hour period and it doesn't go up it
doesn't go down it just kind of hovers
there for months at a time which is
really weird does anyone seen this
before by the way hands up if you've
seen it okay a few of you fantastic now
this is a problem there's actually a
much bigger problem like this is because
the Antarctic and the Arctic are weird
no matter where you are even if you're a
pretty normal spot you've got this
problem let's have a look at this what
do we have a look at this is this is a
world map okay you might have worked out
that the yellow dots are planes now it's
a bit hard to see because the projectors
not the greatest but do you see this
line here it's kind of like a shadow
moving across or it's not kind of like a
shadow it is exactly a shadow what do
you have your look at sir I'm gonna get
this to play again so you can see it
what are we having a look at this is
this is the Sun this is where daylight
is on the earth and of course like I
showed you before because we live on a
round planet you can't have sunlight on
every part of the planet at the same
time in other words just returning to
that original question right this
happens at a different time for
everybody right and that's why the Handy
I'd like you to make is international
time zones international time zones okay
now let's have a look for example you
guys are going to open up to this
shortly but you don't need to have it
right in front of you immediately let's
have a look at this now this is that
same world map that you were having a
look at before but what's superimposed
on top of it have a look down the bottom
here I know it's small but I wanted to
see the whole thing you've got all the
different times at different points on
the earth right so you got here in the
middle Greenwich does anyone know why we
have Greenwich is such an important spot
Jessica okay so we've got latitude and
longitude which are our two ways of
putting coordinates on the earth Jessica
are you talking about latitude which by
the way is actually on these horizontal
lines these are latitudes the other ones
are called there
yep the lines of longitude right so we
have this particular line of longitude
right it's called the Greenwich meridian
why is that one special yeah
it's also called the Prime Meridian it's
called like the most important one and
there's where you think you yes and it
is spelled Greenwich but it is
pronounced Greenwich because you know
English language in Greenwich there's
this place called the Royal Observatory
and I'm in the late 19th century kind of
late 1800s that's when they decided you
know what we should have times set at
different points on the earth because of
this you know problem with this
spherical planet that we live on ok so
you've got you can see here from 0
degrees this is the Prime Meridian that
we were just talking about if you go
east we measure in degrees 180 this way
and if you go west you're 180 that way
and depending on how east and west you
are you get different times does anyone
know by the way we used to call it
Greenwich Mean Time but I think now we
call it I'm gonna zoom in there UTC it
stands for right there it stands for
coordinated Universal Time I don't know
why that C is on the end but whatever
they don't know what our time zone is in
Sydney its UTC plus well we're in Sydney
so that's eastern time so Sydney
Melbourne Brisbane we're all the same
time it's plus it's usually plus 10
there is something that changes that by
the way which is daylight savings right
so it changes back and forth an hour now
yeah Jessica we're gonna we're gonna
come to that in a second so daylight
saving is a bit of a sneaky thing in
order to have a bit of more of a
conversation around this this is the map
you're going to use when you'll have
your way through this exercise but I
want to show you a better map because
it's one which raises a lot more
questions there we go all right so have
a look at this monster now what you can
see here and which you couldn't see in
the previous map because wasn't detailed
enough is you've got these individual
time zones so roughly speaking every
single one of these is an hour apart but
not all of them as an example let me
zoom in to Australia
so here's us right here what do you
notice about these time zones
yeah they're kind of kind of who here in
awkward I should point out we are
basically at Tim this is at nine and a
half most of what all of W a with one
little exception is at UTC plus eight so
there's about a two-hour difference
there and there is this little spot here
I'm gonna zoom back into it
what's that anyone know what that is has
anyone lived in W a in part of their
time yeah now this is agency when I
first saw this I was like is this a
Harry Potter joke like it and I was like
no that's that's platform 9 and 3/4
what's that about there's this little
tiny West Australian town it's like 50
people in ER called nuke lot like
eucalyptus in eucla which is the most
it's the most eastern part of Western
Australia because it's so close to these
guys where it's more like nine and a
half they they all say look that's too
that's too far so plus eight is too far
so we are plus eight and three-quarters
everyone in the town actually observes
that time this idea of daylight saving
is not shown on the map why do you think
that is all countries do daylight saving
slightly differently there are actually
some countries that don't observe it
does anyone know and this is coming to a
question about Brisbane Jessica do you
know which part of Australia observe
daylight saving which don't anyone
Willian what do you think okay so
Queensland doesn't observe it Northern
Territory doesn't observe it waa
doesn't observe it and so in fact it's
sort of this lower right hand corner
lower right hand corner the south east
corner of Australia so New South Wales
Melbourne South Australia and Tasmania
and there's an island somewhere here
that I can't remember that also does it